okay thanks bye it's kind of sad but my
relationship with my phone is my longest
most intimate relationship everybody who
knows me they know what's going on in my
life all the time because always on
snapchat stories or Instagram stories
you so much anything I do on my phone is
a waste of time unless I'm doing
something for work I have little to no
idea what I will be doing except for the
fact that it involves my phone and kind
of going off the grid a little bit okay
I'm gonna get it back oh no no we had
this is just oh no this is the phone my
grandmother has I do like to look but
like functionally what am I supposed to
do with this okay am I supposed to use
this for a week oh no oh it has a camera
this is where I say I love you guys wish
me luck and hopefully I survive it you
can have it I just I can't look at it
anymore
one last selfie before I go it's the
first official day I'm taking this
challenge very seriously someone over
here doesn't know how to turn on her own
phone look at the air we live in these
privileged Millennials these days the
homescreen that we have on our iPhones
I don't know what the rush I am
currently in the bathroom I have to go
all tall I have to go to Staples I don't
know where staples is decided to print
out Google Maps okay
first comes first letter name had a
fooled of breaking mad contacts for the
first time today and it was a struggle
texting them instead of hitting the
spacebar which are trying to find I hit
Send it literally says this I would go
back flip phones to be honest like I
feel like life was just a simpler time
like we appreciated more when he had
phones actually had to ask my co-workers
what they did over this past weekend and
likewise they had no visibility into
what my weekend look like so now I'm
like super mysterious so the alarm on
the stupid flip phone did not go off
it's now 9:30 and I'm supposed to be at
work at 9:30 so
haven't charged all week by the way and
still alive somehow now I realize how
much battery smartphones actually drink
as long as I have I'm gonna coming the
time and so I'm going to tell me when
the train comes I am good I am looking
at pornhub.com on a flip phone right now
and it's a horrible user experience I'm
gonna have to go offline for this I'm
becoming very irritable very quickly it
is really hindering my work because I
can't like get my emails get my slack
messages I'm su Mochis this is my life
now so we're just gonna wander around
the streets of New York oh it's a rainy
can I just look at your GPS I might have
to do that over the past few days I've
been a lot more productive than I've
been in a very long time because I'm not
texting here and checking in with apps
there is a Friday or the last day that
this menu
I am vlogging from Hawaii today after a
week of no iPhone I feel like I'm
getting back from a little mini vacay so
I thought this is appropriate learned a
trick with my phone watch at this point
I've gotten pretty freakin good at
living life without an iPhone
I've even figured out some hack with my
flip phone I'm going to treat myself to
a nice dinner and I think I might go
tech free for dinner I mean might just
leave everything including the stupid
flip phone I don't think it's like
really dramatic but like it's Costco
addiction we're like you think you can't
live without something and then you're
like I'm fine the world is fine they
don't need my interest stories and I
don't need they're the main thing that I
noticed was I was just keeping my head
up more and like I was just looking
around and noticing things I hadn't
noticed before I read parts of a couple
different books
it was just mainly like giving up social
media that was kind of a struggle
especially because I did go out a lot oh
my god really cool right you can put on
Instagram
thank you dude I love you also I had to
carry around a map of Manhattan in my
purse if anything this has made me more
reliant on my iPhone because I felt like
a part of me was missing I wasn't so
easily accessible and people couldn't
reach me it was just a lot more present
and everything that I did and I've never
been like so focused sometimes you've
just got to live in the moment it's
better you letting your own life than
like posting on social media and having
other people envy yours I just feel like
I'm in a better mental spiritual place
my last words to this flip phone are
ready to be reunited with my iPhone
[Music]
future have to start in my hands it
feels great and I feel complete
personally I'm gonna go take a bunch of
selfies
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]